Guys, let me know if you can hear me in the chat, please.
I don't see anybody on, but let's go ahead and just wait a second here, see if I'm actually
live.
Okay, we've got one person on.
Maybe that's me.
I'm going to wait a second.
My chat, Facebook's terrible.
I can't even see who's on.
It's awesome.
If you can see me, hear me, please comment below, okay?
In the comments.
I'm going to be quick on this.
I'd like to have a few people on live.
If not, I'll just go anyway, but let's go ahead and see.
I'm going to wait one, two minutes and I'm going to hop on.
Can you hear me?
Let me know in the chat.
If you can, make a comment, make an emoji, do something, but I just want to, just real
quick, I'm going to be five, 10, 15 minutes.
If you're lucky, it's going to be much less than that, okay?
Can you hear me?
Okay, see a few people on.
Beautiful.
All right.
Unfortunately, I can't see your comments come in real time, but I do see some comments
that keep refreshing.
Kevin, what's up, dude?
Nicholas Kudlick, what's up?
Kevin says, what's up, homie Nick?
What's going on?
Laura Shepard can hear me.
Guys, welcome to the call.
This is going to be a quick little live.
I hadn't even planned on doing this.
I had planned on doing something else, but I just want to say something as a follow-up.
Jason Allred, what's up, dude?
Guys, it is, what is today, March 19th.
For me, it's almost 5 p.m., it's 4.48.
We're almost done with quarter one, which is pretty wild, pretty exciting, also scary
if you're not doing anything with your business or your life, but guys, I was thinking about
this the other day and I've been thinking about it and I want you guys to really put
yourself in this frame of thought and then also I'm going to tell you why I'm bringing
this up to you right now, but imagine if the deal structure that you had, imagine if there
was no flat fee, if there was no paper lead, if there was no commission, if there was no
joint venture.
Imagine that the only way you got paid as a marketer, as a lead generator, as somebody
who owns a lead generation agency, imagine if the only way that you got paid was if
and when your customer made money.
Not when they got the lead, not at the first of the month, not on the 15th of the month,
not every week, only when your clients made money.
If that was the case, how differently would you attack it?
How differently would you treat the relationship with your business owner?
How differently would you be in your selection of the people that you choose to work with?
It would be radically different.
For me, if I think about that, it would be radically, radically different.
What would you expect out of your business owner?
Would you tolerate your business owner not answering the phone?
Would you tolerate your business owner or even think about working with somebody that
didn't show up to the Zoom meeting or show up or respond back to a phone call or treated
a customer like, crap, would you do that?
No, because the only way that you would be getting paid is if they made money and so
you would hold them to a certain expectation.
Guys, the reason I'm bringing this up is this is kind of going back to last week's live
that I did.
If you guys didn't see it, go check it out, guys.
Last week I went live.
I can't even remember what I called it.
I think I called it Porter's step-by-step guided 10th, 11,700, whatever it was.
Basically, I just went on a rant about what the heck are you guys doing?
Why is no one making money?
Why is no one doing anything?
And thank goodness from that I saw a bunch of people make posts.
They are doing stuff.
For some reason people just don't want to talk about it.
By the way, thank you.
Shout out to AJ.
Shout out to Gina.
Shout out to Vaughn.
Shout out to Porter.
Shout out to all these people that are actually posting their deals and doing stuff.
The point is, guys, is that basically, well, not basically, going off of that live that
I did, I'm sitting here and I'm not thinking about this as much with my rank and rent clients.
I'm not thinking about this as much as my agency.
But I'm thinking about that with you guys is I'm sitting here going, sometimes I let
you guys come in here and, of course, you guys pay to be here.
Thank you.
I appreciate you putting your trust in me.
I appreciate you giving me your hard-earned cash.
And I will not disappoint you.
I will show up.
I will be here.
I don't care if I have to miss something.
Tonight I've got to get on an 11 o'clock thing because of the time zone.
I chose to be here.
That's part of the game.
I will deliver.
But then once I let you guys in, I haven't been that good about holding you accountable.
I haven't been that good about sticking it to you guys.
And I think part of the reason is because I'm like, well, they paid and it's really
their decision if they want to make money.
And I'm just tired of that, right?
I'm super, super tired of that.
And I want to start treating you guys as if I don't get paid until you make money.
And maybe I'm going to start charging that once you get in for the first five deals,
I don't know, maybe we'll start restructuring the payment.
You're going to pay the same amount to get in, then you're going to give me a percentage
of the, I don't know, well, I don't know.
Maybe not.
Maybe probably not.
Okay.
But I don't know.
But I'm just, I just want you guys to hear me and hear my enthusiasm and also my frustration
that I'm guys, we're adults.
We're adults.
I've read every one of you that's on here right now, every single person that's commented.
Thank you.
I read your application.
I probably got on your call.
I saw the pain that you were going through, the reason why you're in this group, the reason
why you want to become financially free, the reason why you want to make money renting
out simple websites so you can stop letting your kids down, so you could take care of
your mom, so you can stop having regret and you're not going to wake up one day and have
a bunch of things that you wish you would have done.
You told me all these things.
Oh, I just have to make a change.
I can't be under someone's thumb and I'm tired of the nine to five and blah, blah, blah.
What are you doing about it though?
What are you doing?
I know some of you guys that heard my other live here are like, oh, here he goes again,
but guys, what have you done in the last week and a day?
What have you done in the last eight days since I came on here and tried to blast everyone
and said, what have you guys done?
How many times do you have to be reminded?
If you guys didn't see that, please go watch it.
I'm talking to grown ass adults and I swore I wasn't going to curse, but I'm talking to
grown ass adults here.
You guys aren't kids.
You're not in high school.
You're not forced to be here.
You guys paid to be in this group.
You guys forget that?
You paid me money to be in this group and now you're not doing shit with it.
What have you done?
What have you done in the last week?
I want to know.
I want to know somebody that's brave enough.
Tell me what you've done in the last eight days to make money.
It doesn't include dicking around on Weebly and doing this.
I'm talking about how many people have you asked for money?
Last week, Porter asked somebody for money Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday,
Saturday.
He asked people for money six days of the week.
No wonder he's at $11,700.
Francesca, if you guys didn't know this, was it last Thursday?
I can't remember.
No.
Sorry.
Monday, she got on a call.
She lost the deal.
She lost.
Tuesday, she got another call.
That one went sideways.
Yesterday afternoon, she got on another one and got the deal.
It's little wonder that she's landed deals three of the last four weeks and she will
land another one this week because I will make sure that she does.
What are you doing?
This is a rhetorical question, but I also would love for somebody to be brave enough
to answer the question.
By the way, I can't see your comments, so whatever you're commenting, I'm going to try
to refresh it here in a second, but what are you doing?
What are you doing?
What are you doing with your business?
When is enough going to be enough?
When are you going to stop?
Are you going to really see how pathetic it is that you not only paid money to be in here,
but you're actually not doing anything?
You're actually not ... What I think I should start doing is when you come in, you pay the
money and you give me some ridiculously embarrassing piece of information that I can blackmail
you with, and if you don't hit your damn goals, I'm going to post it online.
Maybe that would be the thing, but guys, it's like every day I'm sitting here and I'm looking
at certain people that keep talking, I'm going to do it.
I saw a bunch of comments, oh, I got the kick in the pants from Nick.
Cool, what have you done?
What have you done?
I hope you understand, some of you guys are probably sitting there going, well, Nick,
what does it matter?
You've already gotten paid.
It means everything.
How do I keep growing this group?
How do I get feedback on what's working, what's not, if you guys aren't doing anything?
To be honest, I feel like I'm like my football coach back in high school when everyone just
wanted to grow their hair out and be cool and they didn't really want to hit the gym
and eat good and they cared way more about being cool than they did about actually winning
football games.
I was like, dude, this guy's psycho.
I'm the psycho now.
Read the slide edge.
Read 10 pages of the slide edge every single day.
Do that and implement what it says in that book.
I gave you guys the book.
I know Porter's reading it because I'm following up with him.
I hit Kyle up today.
I said, Kyle, are you reading your book?
Yes.
Are you doing your sales training every day?
Are you hitting the gym every day?
Yes.
Boom.
Little wonder.
He's only lost three deals this entire month.
He's closing above 90%.
Go figure.
Go freaking figure.
Paul King says he converted two commission clients to flat rate, got a referral, charged
them a set up fee to build himself.
Beautiful.
Paul King doing work.
Post it, bro.
Post that crap, bro.
I want to know.
By the way, for these that are shy about posting, people are going to judge who cares.
It's way ... You're going to get ... That's awesome, dude.
You're making moves.
You're shaking moves.
Some of you guys are like, oh, I want to get a post.
By the way, most of the deals that we've been landing lately are just smaller deals.
Guess what?
We're building that muscle of asking people for money on landing deals.
Paul, great job.
Make a post about it.
Let's let people know about it.
Let's get people excited.
What are you guys freaking ... I'm so glad that Paul said something.
I'm going to give Francesca a shout out.
I'm going to yell at her for not posting about it if she hasn't already, haven't checked
the group.
Francesca's doing work.
Porter's doing work.
Kyle's doing work.
My inner circle's doing work because I'm making them.
I'm not making them, but I'm hopefully inspiring them.
I'm telling them, like, hey, I'm going to hold you accountable.
I texted Kyle this morning, like I said, and I'm like, I'm holding you accountable, bro.
Have you done this, this, and this?
I have a group chat with my two brothers, not just Porter, my other one.
I'm like, hey, are you guys reading ... They're also reading the book.
What are you doing?
You paid to be here.
You paid great money to be here.
I'm showing up every single week.
I'm constantly giving you guys new things to think about, new things to work on.
We have amazing support.
You guys have somebody that helps you with ads.
You guys have somebody that helps you with all tech issues.
You guys have Kyle.
You have myself.
You have Ashley.
You have Porter.
You have Jason.
You have the exact blueprint that we used to close three other last four weeks closed
deals that Porter's using.
He's at $11,700 per month.
What are you doing?
What the heck are you doing?
I want you to think about it like that.
Before you get angry or get frustrated that I keep coming at you, I'm going to keep coming
at you because I want you to feel bad.
I want you to feel like scum because if you're in this group and you're not doing anything,
then you should.
If you didn't ask somebody for money today, if you didn't prospect, guys, every single
one of you, if you're not on the phone every single day, Monday through Friday, go ahead,
take the weekend off.
I don't care.
I know when I was coming up, I was working Saturday mornings minimum and I have kids
and I got other stuff too, but I was working Saturday mornings doing sales calls.
I was doing something sales related every single day of the week.
You may not have the ability to ask somebody for money every single day because you don't
have enough deals in the pipe.
Every single one of you should be on the phone doing prospecting calls every single day,
but Nick, I don't have a campaign that's generating leads.
Who cares?
Go pick a random city and practice.
Get good at doing it while you're waiting or go hook somebody in advance.
Find the area that you want to go into and hook somebody while you wait for the leads
to come in.
I mean, heaven forbid.
Guys, the work that actually moves the needle is talking to business owners, doing sales.
That's the work that matters.
How much have you done this week?
My guess is that 99% of you guys haven't done jack shit.
That's the truth.
Well, I watched some training videos.
I watched the live.
I spent an hour looking at due diligence.
Cool.
Good job.
Go do 100, then outsource it.
Go do 100 due diligence.
Master the process of finding a city and niche.
Go hire someone for pennies in the Philippines and get that off your plate and focus on sales.
Oh, but I wrote content.
Awesome.
Get 20,000 words of content for your first five websites.
Train somebody for the Philippines or Africa or whatever.
Create a process.
Outsource it.
Spend more time on sales.
You want to make more money?
Don't sit there and think that you're doing work because you're watching videos or you're
listening to freaking Joe Rogan or you're listening to Jocko Willink talking about
getting in the ice bath.
Do sales.
Call people.
Knock on doors.
Do anything.
Listen to Facebook group.
Call your dad who's a real estate agent.
Call your uncle who's a real estate agent.
Go do something.
Okay?
But don't sit there.
Oh, my campaign.
I'm just waiting for my campaign.
Just waiting for you to come in.
Let me message Fix It Felix and ask another question.
Go do some work.
Okay?
It's been a long 10 cents.
I dropped the F word on this and I'm getting close on this call.
Go do some actual work and quit talking about the work you're going to do and start doing
the actual work.
I'm going to start treating this as if I have not made any money and then until you guys
get a deal, I have not made any money.
I'm going to have to frame my mind like that and that's how I'm going to start treating
you guys.
And the reality is that the way that most of you are acting and if I had structured this
program as I only get paid if you guys make money, 90% of you I wouldn't have let in this
program.
90% of you I wouldn't have let in here because you're not doing shit.
You're not doing anything.
And I would have known from the beginning that you weren't going to do anything because
it's a bunch of fuzz.
It's a bunch of just talking.
Most of you guys don't actually have enough pain that you want to get out of your situation.
You're just comfortable being in freaking mediocre-ville.
Awesome dude.
Congrats.
Go ahead and keep doing it.
And blame me.
Blame me.
Program doesn't work.
Works for Porter.
Works for Kyle.
Works for Francesca.
Made me millions.
Made Ryan Dalton a millionaire.
But it doesn't work for you because you have a special scenario.
I get it.
90% of you, yes this is you, I wouldn't have let in this program if I only got paid on
you getting deals.
And not because it doesn't work, but because you're not doing anything.
Because you're not doing anything.
And it's sad.
It's a damn shame.
That's the truth.
Raphael, pitch the business on last Friday.
Great.
Post it, dude.
I love freaking hearing that.
Raphael, pitch it.
That's work.
Pitch the deal.
Call the business owner.
That's work.
Pitch the business owner last Friday.
Waiting for lead to offer him.
Great.
Google CPC was too expensive for me so I started Facebook.
That's great.
Cool.
Doing work.
Jason says we need to be held accountable.
Thanks, Nick.
We'll have to be called out.
Jason, somebody who's at $13,000.
Of course, it's always the people that are actually doing work that don't mind being
called out because they're actually doing the work.
Go figure.
Okay.
It's funny that the people that are always sitting at the front of the meetings, when
you have the meetings that you're supposed to be at when no one sales, the bagel meetings,
you don't even have to be there if you got sales.
The people that got the sales are the ones on the front row with the pen and paper, ready
to learn.
That's Jason Allred.
That's why he's going to be a millionaire with his business, okay?
I wish we were in person so I could freaking just like ring some necks, okay?
Anyway, guys, I'm not giving up on you.
I want to just be like, hey, I'm done.
I'm tired.
Like, screw you guys.
You don't want to make money.
But I'm not going to do that because I know that you guys have the right model.
I know you guys have the right vehicle.
I've seen it change my life.
It's literally completely transformed my entire world.
It's allowed me to do things I never thought I'd be able to do at this age.
It's allowed me to go places, buy things, take care of people I never thought I could
do at this stage at 34 years old, okay?
It got me out of debt.
It's given me confidence that I can't even describe, that I can take care of those around
me.
It's done everything for me, this business model and this exact program, these steps,
these scripts, these niches that I'm going into, these things that I'm talking about.
You guys are so damn tired of getting messages about, oh, this doesn't work.
You didn't know where the script's at?
Dude, if you don't know how to find something in the Facebook group, then just ask AI.
You know what you could do?
Go to chat GPT or Google, which has AI at the top.
How do I find an answer to my question in the Facebook group?
Some of you guys need to do that, okay?
Quote waste of my time sending me a message about where the script is.
Go look.
Go freaking look.
I was watching this video yesterday about learning, how to learn, and the guy's like,
you should outline the project.
You should say, hey, here's what I want to do is I'm going to build this project and
then start, and then you're going to have the questions that you need to answer, and
then you're going to go find those answers.
Guess what?
Because you had to struggle, because you had to look, you actually are going to remember
the things that you found.
Why do you guys think that when you message me 400 times to get an answer that takes
you 10 seconds to find, I don't respond, or I tell my team to hold off?
Because if I'm just sitting there spoon feeding you, I'm turning you into nothing.
You're not going to become anything.
Guys, it's every answer to every one of your questions, I promise you, is in this group.
This group's been around for three years.
Every question's been asked.
If it's not here, it's in the Q&A section of the Kajabi training.
If it's not there, it's in one of the modules.
You're going to have to look a little bit, but guess what?
You're actually going to remember it.
Stop spending time on stupid stuff.
Stop.
You should be doing cold calls every single day, because that's the one thing that's going
to make you money.
That's all I got.
I'm out.
See you guys.